[Music]
thanks everybody so I'm going to start
off today's presentation the same way I
start off most of the conversations I've
had about this the last two years and
that's filling us in on what exactly
eSports are you give the word you might
think of a few things and often
conversations I just say it's
professional gaming and we not at each
other and kind of go from there without
any more attention but now that I have a
little bit more captives an audience I'm
gonna explain it so it's this really
fascinating trend in gaming and actually
it's spawned this really cool industry
that is really that's mashing together
convergence of geek and jock ultra which
for all intents purposes we've been
trained to think are diametrically
opposed so it's at times really
fascinating and other times really
frightening it's it's still fraught with
a lot of issues of lack of diversity
sexism and you name it it's still very
white male dominated and still a very
growing kind of inappropriate culture
that is still finding its way around but
the thing to keep in mind is that it's
not just this professional level that
I'm going to be talking about here I'm
focusing mainly on the very highest
level with the highest states the big
broadcast but it goes all the way down
to the lowest grassroots things we have
these sports clubs here at MIT who just
a group of students get together and
they can if they want to broadcast their
game to a much larger audience anytime
they're involved in a few different
these that are depleted levels that are
getting same sorts of things you're
seeing in these big broadcasts the only
thing I want to point out is that this
often comes with did he just say sport
house house
sitting down playing video game sport
and I don't want to rehash that argument
and I don't think that this discussion
here has anything to do with that
argument you'll see me constantly
referring to and preparing to
traditional sports broadcast models
because that's really what e sports
broadcasting borrows from and how
they're informed so it's really
important to acknowledge that but I
don't need to talk to you about whether
darts or chess is a sport or video
gaming is a sport I just don't think
it's that important and lastly I want to
point out the thing that really makes
eSports look and it's view like sports
in these broadcasts and that's the
shoutcasters which I could give you a
verbal explanation of but I'd much
rather just show you
[Music]
[Applause]
and Mike and Bonnie just walked up into
the nothingness of that was the
difference between sad a body today he
takes that fight that we've been looking
for and that my body was not the best
move and now sanjeok surpasses the
golden opportunity to finally go through
the semi-finals poly halted back behind
the cellphone tower but this is sad
chance he brings that last couple back
across will go on touch and a big series
on going to five gate is gonna go in
favor
so it's it's pretty fun stuff new the
audio was more important in the video
here because this is probably gibberish
to you anyway the cool thing to note
here is that it sounds like a sports
broadcast is kind of indistinguishable
you just took the audio track out on top
of that you have you have branding here
in the top corner you also have new ways
that they're figuring out how to get
sponsors and logos into the actual
gameplay itself so it's really taking on
this kind of Monday Night Football feel
[Music]
so that brings me to my actual project
which is eSports broadcasting in
comparison with traditional sports
broadcasting models and my main thread
of this whole thing is that P sports
broadcasting is informed by and follow
this trajectory set out by a traditional
sports media but it's not really in a
position to be able to copy those things
wholesale and it's actually running into
a few issues here so it's time to
innovate where it can't just copy and
attempt to kind of learn the hard way
that not all of these things are
replicable so to break down the the
presentation today I'm going to start
with a discussion of those shoutcasters
which the word shoutcaster comes from
the old software they used to do is
called shoutcast which was very early
early
it's streaming software that allow these
guys to watch a game and then give audio
commentary much like sports radio and
broadcast it to into small and internet
radio stations where maybe a few hundred
people were here in the entire lifetime
of the broadcast and that word the
shoutcast FM has really held on it
signals the history of this and a shark
aster is effectively just an eSports
caster so it's the exact same role but
they actually have taken on a lot more
responsibility than your traditional
sports casters so they are in this kind
of flexed position of balancing
traditional sports casting with gaming
gaming and sports are different they
they pose different challenges and these
guys are are in between the two of them
they also see community maintenance as a
really important part of their job and
that's one of the cool things about
eSports is that it's gotten really big
but it's not big enough that you don't
know what's going on everywhere in
eSports and the first generation of
asteroids these guys from the early
two-thousands they really their only
touch points were in traditional sports
broadcasting this second generation of
casters that are just emerging now that
it's getting huge all of them don't look
to traditional sports as the primary
touch point but instead of looking at
other eSports casters so you're seeing a
disconnect starting to form from eSports
casting and traditional sports casting
and I just want to mention here that
this will work with my field work with
the ESL and also I was able to do a
whole bunch of interviews with
professional shoutcasters so all of this
data is coming from those interviews and
those conversations I've had countless
conversations while that ESL about all
these things the next thing I'll be
jumping into is sports media and eSports
and kind of situating eSports
broadcasting and especially live
streaming in the larger media landscape
of traditional sports caster traditional
sports have started streaming a little
known fact that
in 2003 MLB actually broadcast a
thousand games online not many people
really know that it even happened and it
wasn't that successful but they were
doing it to have been doing it for a
while but they are in this kind of
difficult position of finding out
exactly what they should be doing so I'm
going to talk about the the different
transitions from print all the way to
live streaming and these transitional
moments of creating different sort of
touch points in uncollected conventions
while creating your own finally I'm
going to look at the revenue streams for
both what you're seeing happening with
the sponsorships and logos showing up
that I showed you there is these sports
broadcasting is borrowing almost
wholesale from traditional sports but
their revenue streams aren't identical
and they're actually very different in a
few different ways that I'd like to get
into later but by looking at these
revenue streams you can really see that
the traditional sports model is
inseparable you can't take the NFL's
revenue stream which is sometimes not a
revenue stream and put that in eSports
it just won't work so starting out
talking about shoutcasters in general
this this image here is showing you
[Music]
once you got in this temple last lecture
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so looking at this image here Wow
first time I don't look back so just
showing you the transition the the top
image is the same guys at the bottom
image and that is from 2009 so that's an
event from 2009 and then the the lower
picture is just from about three weeks
ago and you can see the like crazy
transition from long hair and t-shirt
jeans broadcaster to what effectively is
a traditional sportscaster and if Joe is
watching us itself quite I'm really
sorry that I dragged that picture out so
these guys are somewhere in between
sportscasters and the community there
they're both fans and professionals and
it's an interesting dichotomy that they
talk about a lot in these interviews
so they all kind of got their start in
this grassroots do-it-yourself and a lot
of people like to talk about the passion
and the cult of passion any sports where
it's just a bunch of people were really
really into gaming really really into
eSports and they go out of their way for
great lengths to to kind of create a
profession out of this and the
shoutcasters are really a perfect
example of this and they're the what I
would argue the primary signifier of
this sports part of eSports so if you
look at some of the earlier casters they
they will without blinking just let you
know that their roots are in traditional
sports casting the the earliest one I
don't have would take his laptop and he
set it up and he let me know that he
would listen to hours of football and
soccer radio just to kind of learn those
the transition moments how to hand off
the end of the segment how to handle
dead air all those things that he was
just a gamer he had no idea what he was
doing but he took it upon himself to
educate himself by going to traditional
sports casting so they borrowed those
transitions though
and even the Wardrobe has started to
resemble traditional sports they've
they've gotten the whole game they they
started with the t-shirt and jeans went
all the way up to full suit and time and
realized well there might be a little
too much we're still we're still gamers
we're still geeks and we're going to
reflect that through our work or truce
they brought it back down a little bit
but there's not that much of a
difference there so one really crazy
thing about eSports is that a career in
this people talk about burnout rates
constantly and one of the big issues is
that a career in eSports might last two
years a professional player who is
between eighteen and twenty might have
one season worth playing in them and
very few go beyond three or four years
ever the same thing with organizations
and coaches you have teams that will
form and disband within a year some
notable exceptions to that
like fnatic or SK gaming have been
around for quite a long time but they
constantly are or shuffling through
rosters and there's almost no kind of
standing backbone of eSports besides
these eSports companies and these
shoutcasters who end up becoming the
gatekeepers for the community they
become the history keepers and the stack
keepers there's no place to go for all
the stats from the earlier two esports
matches it's just lucky to find out who
won match five years ago much less get
the actual nitty-gritty details from it
but these shoutcasters go out of their
way to aggregate this stuff they all
have their own databases and there's
been an influx of those sites popping up
with the help of api's and shoutcasters
to really formalize the the stats in
this to resemble traditional sports so
another thing that comes in is this
broadcast persona these guys become the
face of eSports they from the sound of
eSports and as as you could tell there
there's not much of a difference in the
audio so they resemble traditional
sports casters and then building on
traditional sports casters and news
ingress they become a sort of
personality that
interact with and this is known as para
social interaction Oh nom I have to head
in the back there who did a great
meta-analysis of this to find out that
by creating a persona and becoming a
character with regular schedule and
broadcasting you make a greater
connection and actually put people in
more often but this comes back to the
actual medium of live streaming which is
both the audiovisual feed and an
Internet Relay Chat next nextdoor so you
have everybody whether it is ten
thousand or two hundred all the people
in that twitch stream are able to chat
with one another and the broadcaster's
can link right into that chat as well
and respond to it and often do
so these shoutcasters are very aware of
that and have taken it as their duty to
kind of do this community maintenance
get information out there and respond to
the community building this kind of
really great rich connection and then
you have the second generation of
casters coming in now that are throwing
off the traditional school its model
altogether and there are only touch
points are these earlier casters so
they've learned things like hand and na
or or handling a hand off at the end of
the segment from their other casters and
one of them even told me like I don't I
don't watch sports at all I don't
there's nothing I can learn from it
which is this amazing disconnect from
his earlier casters because although
they looked at and all they learn from
was traditional sports so they've kind
of taken this community and aspect to
the next level and see it has almost a
requirement that every broadcast they
will respond to his dream they will let
people know like hey I'm just make you
have feedback I'll check it out while
the older casters look at it more like
yeah I understand that the feedbacks
there but I'm not gonna not really gonna
engage with it or not these guys aren't
professional casters so I'll go talk to
other hashes if I want feedback about
what I'm doing so it really boils down
to what live streaming is and what they
have access
- so the text is kind of small and I saw
I'll help you out with that but through
the evolution of sports media you have
live streaming emerging relatively
recently I mean the first really good
live streaming platforms were early
2000s with justin.tv and what we're
streaming on right now Ustream showing
up around 2007-2008 and twitch TV the
primary streaming platform for live
streaming before eSports is only a few
years old came out in 2011 and has since
blown up you might have noticed recently
that Amazon acquired them for 970
million so you have eSports emerging at
a time where it was prohibitively
expensive to get into to live streaming
and it was also almost impossible to
break into television television has
kind of been set it's it's tough to get
into and for a long time these sports
casters and companies thought that the
way to go would be to get into
traditional sports I mean into
television broadcasts and TL has a great
case study about the CGS which was this
kind of early partnering of DIRECTV with
really big names in the eSports industry
in 2007 and 2008 and the first artists
attempt to bring eSports to television
and it failed pretty miserably so it was
once again relegated to live streaming
the interesting thing about live
streaming is that it's more accessible
than television but as it grows up it's
kind of brushing into these these other
entities you have print coming out of
this you have audio cast podcasts coming
up from eSports and the streams are
resembling television more often than
not and this live streaming image I have
here is just from two nights ago
actually there's you can't see there but
90,000 people and
check so it's almost unintelligible it
becomes almost the roar of a stadium
because nobody can read it and it just
as memes and emoticons you name it so as
we look at the different agendas of each
of these media print and and radio very
early on focused certainly as sports
news they're their goal is to get the
information they're to get fans to be
able to tune in and find out what's
going on this world
it wasn't until kind of the Golden Age
of baseball and radio that you saw this
news switchover anton entertainment
which television and live streaming have
both really taken up this mantra of
entertainment before news and with this
you see a massive commercialization so
television in particular you might see
some of those area figures come out
which I'll get into shortly of just this
huge amounts of sponsorship dollars of
media rights going into these events and
live streaming is sort of sort of
starting tomorrow from that as well and
it's funded primarily through through
sponsorships and public relations so one
thing I wanted to point you with the
live streaming is that it's actually a
melding together of a few of these so
William Hamilton at all just a few years
ago we took out the McLuhan and
Oldenburg's ideas of hot cold media as
well as three places to situate
live-streaming as this kind of new
entity which creates this third place
for communities to kind of coalesce and
connect really richly and I'm just gonna
give a quick quote from that it says by
combining hot pool media streams enable
sharing rich ephemeral experiences in
tandem with open participation through
informal social interaction ingredients
for a third place so what do you mean
spy hot cold media which is coming
directly from McLuhan is that
you're televisual broadcast it's very
hot media it's very active and then
something like print or or the Internet
Relay Chat an extra stream is going to
be a totally different act interaction
and a totally different way of engaging
with this broadcast but combining the
two creates this kind of an interesting
space in general so that brings me to my
my conversation here of the revenue
stream so as I mentioned they're models
in traditional sports casting that just
don't fit into eSports and the primary
one I'd like to apply here is that media
rates in traditional sports account for
31% of the revenue in traditional sports
broadcasting whereas in eSports it
accounts for 4% so they're relying on
completely different sort of mounting
methods here and the media rights kind
of bidding war that started and I'll
just give a quick tip if the NFL sold
his broadcasting rights in 2011 through
the 2020 2021 season for twenty billion
dollars and and that all started back
with Pete Rozelle an NFL commissioner
who kind of got the teams together to
negotiate together originally teams
would sell their media rights to
specific outlets but Pete Rozelle got
them together and then made the the
outlets pump to them so you have NBC CBS
Fox coming to the collective of NFL
they're having to negotiate a kind of
group contract which started back then
with a it went from about $75,000 for
broadcasting rights to a few million in
just a few years and we're now at a
point where they're selling it for 20
billion each of the three big networks
are paying and
1 billion per year just for media rights
in the NFL alone leaving along the rest
of our sports content and these sports
can't really replicate that because you
don't have franchises that have
organized together into a kind of
negotiating body so you don't have a
standalone leave or standalone group of
franchises that are come together there
wasn't attempt at this early on called
the g7 which was an organization of
teams that was focused on really Britain
making better rates for the teams in
general and also proliferating eSports
but since then is sort of defunct and
not really spoken about so what happens
as teams end up having to go to the
other two models which I'll get into in
sports right now and you have one model
where an eSports company comes in so you
have your MLG major league gaming or ESL
which is the sports league both of them
take a publisher's game and then run
events for it so they all created a
legal create a structure they look like
teams and they'll go through that
together with a game that isn't their
own the other model is worked for a
publisher to go ahead and shell out that
money themselves to create a whole
production the events and everything on
their own with the money they make from
the game itself when these two models
don't really leave room for the teams to
kind of form their own group to
negotiate so if you look at Riot Games
for instance they run the League of
Legends Championship Series that's an
example of the model where you have a
publisher of creating a game and then
creating the eSports branch for it and
they cover all the costs and just in
prize money alone in the third season
they spent eight million which is
unheard of in this area to spend on
eSports and they've also acknowledged
that it's not a profit point they're not
making money off of spending into the
LCS what they are getting is an
ancillary benefit of deep connection and
bridging a gap that keeps players
interested but also viewers
arrested the other model the ESL and the
MLG are entirely dependent on publishers
so if you look at this blue text here
other area in relations and sponsorships
account for the majority of the revenue
in eSports and the issue here is how do
you find meteorites is is play
derivative or is play in a
transformative object so if a
professional player plays who owns the
rights to his be is he creating
something unique something individual
and something he could sell himself does
he own that broadcast does the platform
he's on own it or does the game
developer get to come in and say well
you know what it's our game our thing so
you know all along that too so you have
a really sticky situation here where
eSports are in constant kind of a
precarious position because at any
moment a publisher would say I don't
want you broadcasting my game anymore
where we're done after this contract
edge then you no longer have that
sponsorship Republican publisher a
relationship and you've lost out on that
entire segment there so it's a really
interesting battle field around IP that
hasn't really come up too much yet
there's one example of the Korean
eSports players association kind of
signing out media rights and contracts
to a game that haven't come out yet and
when the game eventually did come out
the publisher said you know what I don't
know why you did that we don't want you
to be enemy a sort of thing and they cut
off ties with the company entirely so
that they were in a horrible predicament
of having a contract signed on something
that no longer belong to them so the the
models that are apparent in traditional
sports just don't translate because you
don't have that kind of League
Association you don't have the
Commissioner or the owners of franchises
being able to step in
also in traditional sports you have a
little battle between is it cheaper for
me to buy it out of branch
and get the meteorites from franchise
directly or to negotiate with the
organization as a whole and that's a
constant struggle that's going to happen
in traditional sports that's not really
apparent in useful its right now so what
we're looking at is that traditional
sports probably isn't providing the
model that we want for eSports and they
should maybe move it to a different
model one more like a music festival
that subsists is almost entirely off of
sponsorship money and funding through
other means than meteorites because it's
just not going to work and there's going
to be difficulty in the actual execution
okay so to sum up just to give you some
takeaways here things I want to talk
about are that the next generation of
shoutcasters and that primary signifier
of sports in eSports is turning away
from traditional sports they're kind of
creating their own thing and they're
going to keep running with it so you're
seeing an industry kind of being pulled
in multiple directions one is all of the
one thing I didn't get to mention in the
last slide that I showed is you have a
huge influx of television producers
coming into eSports and dictating the
way that eSports are looking and feeling
and also offering up sponsorship models
so the thing you're running into is
these television producers saying we
want to make it look more like
television if you look at the LCS which
was currently the top watched eSport in
the US and Europe that is run by Ariel
Horne who's an emmy-winning producer
from NBC and their work in the Olympics
and the CGS was actually done by Mike
burns who had won Emmys for his
productions in NHL NBA and NFL so you're
seeing these TV producers come in and
dictate the direction that the broadcast
looks and also talking to the caster is
saying you need to need to do it this
way I'm used to
away I'm going to do it that way but you
have the caster's kind of cognizant of
the community that they've created and
are feeling responsible for that and
maintaining it so you have this
interesting separation of where the
production wants ahead and where the
caster's are kind of already heading
while still maintaining that
relationship with the traditional sports
feel so then the the live streaming as a
medium has these difficulties to figure
out especially on media rights so each
medium has faced a difficult transition
phase when I'm seeing the emergence of
eSports broadcasting identity within the
medium of live stream so instead of
looking to create its own thing it's
almost kind of backtracking unlike the
other sports and other medium it's kind
of becoming an earlier medium it's
becoming more like television instead of
branching off on its in its own
direction where it has this really
really awesome potential to become its
own thing it's really a new thing it's
actually going backwards and finally
traditional sports media models are not
easily replicated especially the NFL one
thing I might point out is that there
are multiple models including FIFA and
[Music]
f1 racing which which problematic from
projectory but are still not not
reputable in eSports one that might work
is actually the n-c-double-a but you
would have to have teams come together
and create kind of organizations that
they doubt their media rights as opposed
to the current model where you have the
eSports company's core the publishers
dictating once you are not so with that
thanks everybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah so you're seeing that happen
already because oftentimes publishers
aren't aren't really making money
through investing eSports but they are
gaining is that ancillary benefit that
exposure and that community basis which
is really important in sports it's
almost entirely intuitive if the people
don't like your name they're just gonna
stop playing it because they have a
million other options to go to you now
so again I would argue that publishers
do need to be open and kind of allow
these these sports companies to pick up
and run with the product to help them
create that community and so far you're
seeing that they're relatively open I
mean the cuspid case is the only one I
know of at this point where it does
become an issue but as things get more
competent anymore money flows into it
you might start seeing some weird things
happen especially using twitch being the
primary platform it currently has a
relationship with all of these different
publishers and it has a relationship
with the eSports companies but in any
moment if they if they
instead to not just let this happen
enough proliferation on their own and
instead of charge to host content on
their platforms or make it much more
prohibitive model then you would see an
entirely shaping of the industry yeah
absolutely
breathing is actually a cardigan or a
virtual parking but the casting tone and
that has to be different because it's a
lot of downtime and a lot of like well
what does he have what they do is so
that it still borrows that to caster
situation where we have one guy kind of
giving me like this is what's going on
this is the the play-by-play and then
your second guys is a really high level
player or or somebody with a lot of
experience to explain to like why they
just did that give the flavor to it so
yeah there are games coming out with
different styles and if you look if you
look across traditional sports too if
you would get German football
they usually have a single caster with
that with no play-by-play / color
commentary it's just one guy giving the
cast saying like oh this this is the guy
who ball and what just happened
so you even have to come variations and
also regional variations
we will sometimes go up to six casters
on one game and League of Legends in
America's has started doing triple
casters for their kind of finals and
stuff they found out that style I have
look too much into the - let's play and
the solo captures are the kind of
eSports players sitting down and
actually broadcasting their games right
where though once in a while and say
what they're doing I would say that
they're radically different in that the
solar caster the let's play guy isn't
it's not formalized in any way and also
that they have a very individual style
some some tomahawks and Joe Ally and I
think it's a very different feeling like
you might you might see as one becomes
more common it might be bleed over there
so many different varieties and lots of
requirement for people to be up to speed
in order to understand what's going on
in the street as you're into this and
maybe the second question would be just
what is the most popular eSport today
yeah so to answer your first question
about kind of the expertise needed and
how that factors into the East Coast for
our customers during you're touching on
something that a lot of the casters do
too in the idea of their audience and
they all have this kind of formulation
of the audience they don't got to and
they all kind of assume that they're
talking to people who play the game a
lot our core players as you know so
there's almost this expectation and this
this barrier entry that the caster is
going out to a hardcore player you're
not a hardcore player this broadcast
really isn't for you they've run into
certain issues where if they know that
oh hey this is a really big event it
might be on ESPN 3 or oh we're gonna be
on television today guys and they they
actively dumb it down and they try to
explain things as low as they possibly
can without using any jargon but they
end up finding out like the the producer
will come to the mat board
say like yeah I need you to tone it down
even more because nobody knows wooden
AWP is like just bring it down a little
bit more so I think that's an issue that
they're coming up against is the
audience but you're starting to see a k2
and IEC I know I'm messing up my
pronunciation but they need actually in
their investigation of eSports
live-streaming we're saying that it's
actually becoming more of a spectator
sport than it is just players so most
not most many people who are entity
stands up into eSports prefer to watch
these high-level eSports over plane
they'd much rather see some high quality
players go at it than they would play
themselves so the audience is shifting
that's for sure the most it's hard to
say that the most popular I would say
right now is League of Legends and
that's top down it looks a little bit
similar to what I showed earlier but
it's a completely different type of game
that's a five versus five your same team
team games are becoming much more
popular what really made eSports blow up
especially in South Korea is Starcraft
which is a one versus one battle of
whit's almost it's almost if you imagine
Czechs an ultra fast pace that's that's
what Starcraft is and that that's what
really blew up in South Korea but right
now the most popular shooter over in
Asia is called crossfire and that's a
that's a one versus one first-person
shooter that goes way back to the
origins of eSports with like quake and
other that one versus one contest so it
varies by region but overall League of
Legends is on top curious
oh he's wondering whether your analysis
is looking solely at the u.s. best
player in movies or whether models
models are different so in what ways
sure I'm focused and I should mention I
in focus primarily on North America and
Europe the ancient scenes both Southeast
Asia and Chinese scenes are very
different and South Korea has long been
this kind of like shangri-la eastwards
and it's really difficult to wrap your
head around because it is so engrained
in every day that it's it's lived
entirely different the political economy
behind it is is different and it is
I mean people return sometimes that
Starcraft was the national sport of
South Korea but there are that many
people into it and follow me that it is
on main stream television it's been on
cable television since 98 maybe the
early 2000 theme that earliest but it
has many many appearances on television
it is successful October in South Korea
which has been shown not to work here so
I haven't really focused on that model
as it is so specific to South Korea and
I would plug Italian Jing's book South
Korea's online gaming Empire here and he
does the fantastic analysis of the
political economies surrounding eSports
in South Korea unless
right thanks